we are now in the corporate oligarchy
that is the Trump administration a White
House press release that was sent out to
reporters yesterday had a paragraph in
it that was identical word for word to a
paragraph in an Exxon Mobil press
release published just an hour before
the White House release is called
president Trump congratulate Exxon Mobil
for job-creating investment program and
it was cheerleading ExxonMobil for new
oil refining which we should be actually
criticizing for chemical manufacturing
developments along the coast of
louisiana and texas which we should
actually be really really concerned
about and the White House release called
president Trump congratulate Exxon Mobil
for job-creating investment program was
different only by one word from what
Exxon Mobil point out okay so there was
a tweet that was sent out yesterday by
Christopher Ingram who pointed out the
similarities between the Trump press
release and the X or the Trump statement
and the Exxon Mobil press release let's
look more closely at the text and as
you'll see here the only difference is
the word expansion and on top you see
the statement from Trump Exxon Mobil is
strategically investing in new refining
and chemical manufacturing projects in
the United States Gulf Coast region to
expand its manufacturing and export
capacity the company is growing the Gulf
program consists of 11 major chemical
refining lubricant and liquefied natural
gas projects that proposed new and
existing facilities along the Texas and
Louisiana coast investments began in
2013 and are expected to continue
through at least 20 22 I won't reread
the one from exxon mobil because it
differs by only one word they're not
even trying are they or i guess they are
trying and they're actively succeeding
in building a kleptocracy Trump
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson of
course the former CEO of Exxon Mobil it
reminds me of when Oklahoma Attorney
General Scott Pruitt received a letter
from an oil and gas company which was
opposed to the federal effort to elicit
methane limit methane gas leaking from
drilling operations and he copied and
pasted that onto his own letterhead and
sent
to the EPA he now is the administrator
of the EPA by the way here's the main
point here okay Donald Trump ran his
campaign as an outsider right not part
of the establishment against corruption
against special interest draining the
swamp all that stuff and he accused his
opponent of being corrupt because of
lobbyists and Wall Street and he'd be
really really different and now his
administration is not figuratively but
literally copying and pasting propaganda
from exxonmobil filling his cabinet and
adviser rules with Goldman Sachs people
ExxonMobil has become a voice of the
administration in the literal sense they
are just repeating propaganda from
exxonmobil a company that knew for
decades about the harmful effects of
their activities to the climate and
covered up that data that now has become
the official word of the trump
administration and in another angle here
too it's another example of Donald Trump
taking credit for something that Barack
Obama did because this investment
started in 2013 and you could say now
they're amping it up really they
shouldn't be doing that because we
should be looking towards alternative
forms of energy I don't think a
Democratic president would have allowed
them to make this investment even more
money over a longer period of time
you're probably right and some portion
of voters were of course concerned that
Hillary Clinton was too cozy with Wall
Street because they paid her to give
speeches it's actually laughable now to
say oh we should have been so worried
about Hillary's speeches Trump's
connections to Wall Street fossil fuel
companies and all sorts of special
interests are hilariously overshadowing
the concerns about Hillary's speeches
but it won't matter because if you
survey Trump capote supporters more than
half think that millions voted illegally
for Hillary Clinton two-thirds believe
that unemployment went up under
President Obama when the reality is it
decreased around fifty percent nearly
three-quarters of Trump supporters
believe that people protesting Trump
after the election were paid by George
Soros and more than half of Trump
supporters questioned whether President
Obama was even born in the United States
copy-pasted language from exxon mobil is
going to mean much to most trumpet and
there's a case to be made that the
entire Trump Russia thing whatever it is
right has oil Russia and ExxonMobil at
its root when you look at the number one
export of Russia when you look at the
geopolitical relationships related to
oil that Russia would love to be
increasingly involved in more and more
people that have been emailing me saying
David you know if you really want to
understand Trump Russia look at
exxonmobil and look at fossil fuels and
there's a very interesting case to be
made there